les lieux du visible une exposition
montée malgré la crise sanitaire pour
maintenir l'activité
en attendant le retour du public
l'exposition est accessible
professionnels et à destination des
scolaires comme tous les lieux culturels
on peut ouvrir uniquement sur rendez
vous donc on reçoit on reçoit des petits
groupes de professionnels dans
l'exposition assez régulièrement une
exposition collective qui réunit quatre
artistes au programme peinture
photographie sculpture et dessin
objectif de l'exposition faire découvrir
des lieux peu visibles voire
inaccessibles au grand public les fonds
sous-marins avec nicolas floch qui a un
parcours assez extraordinaire artiste
bien sûr mais aussi marin et plongeurs
de formation renault patar lui s'est
beaucoup intéressé ces dernières années
à l'univers carcéral
agnès geoffrey elle prend souvent comme
point de départ dans son travail
les archives et timothée schelstraete
donc l'artiste qui présente les
peintures dans l'espace d'exposition qui
lui en fait à une pratique de flâneurs
qui
parcourent la ville prend des
photographies et révèle des détails
auxquels on ne prête généralement pas
d'attention la graineterie et le centre
d'art de la ville de houilles
le lieu était à l'origine une ferme
devenue une graineterie dans les années
d'où son nom la ville a souhaité
conserver son caractère patrimonial
voici la cour centrale c'est le lieu
d'exposition pour le centre d'art et
c'est le lieu autour duquel tout
s'articule en fait tous les lieux de
culture
on a tenu à conserver le caractère rural
et patrimoniale de ce lieu d'où
l'ouverture du silo à grains les
mangeoires dans ce qui s'appelle encore
l'écurie la porte de ferme la vitrine de
l'ancienne boutique
l'exposition les lieux du visible devait
se terminer le 6 mars pour permettre au
public de voir le projet l'installation
est prolongée jusqu'au 22 mai